une 15h30 sur la 12e avenue près de jean
talon ce quartier résidentiel devrait
être tranquille mais n'avait pas
constaté que ceux-ci truelle très très
présente et l'émotionnel et eric vu an
plus léger et revues de style
même phénomène sur la 6e avenue en
direction sud
2h10 on a cinq heures c'est trafic
s'arrête jamais cédé au tos et des
camions ces deux rues permettent
d'éviter les grandes artères et
d'accéder entre autres à l'autoroute 40
j'ai déjà des enfants donc ça c'est sûr
que ça pose des problèmes de sécurité
quand on se promène à pied dans le
quartier les gens sont pressés les gens
veulent aller plus vite
ils font pas nécessairement attention au
stop parmi les automobilistes croisés
dans le quartier des adeptes des
applications de navigation
c'est gourmand oui que voulant protéger
son avance et russie n'ont pas vrai pas
souvent mais quand je me faisais les
quelque part c'est l'objet est
impossible de savoir si ces outils sont
responsables de ces tâches alors d'âge
les chantiers sont aussi en cours dans
le secteur et les voitures sont de plus
en plus nombreuses sur les routes au
revoir ses applications en temps réel ça
va modifier les comportements le sel la
question c'est l'amplitude de cette
modification
personne je pensais répond vraiment à
cette question aujourd'hui dans un
courriel à radio canada google souligne
que divers facteurs sont pris en compte
pour déterminer le meilleur itinéraire
comme le temps de trajet estimé
l'entreprise dit encourager les
utilisateurs à respecter les lois
locales et à faire preuve de jugement
lorsqu'ils sont au volant du côté des
applications n'y a pas grand chose à
faire il ya déjà un bon pas qui était
fait ça a été de réduire la vitesse à 30
km h la ville de montréal traite
actuellement une plainte concernant
l'achalandage sur la 2e avenue
elle ignore pour le moment si de
nouvelles mesures d'apaisement seront
mises en place ici marie-eve cousineau
radio canada montréal